this is a video about things
like cars phones and light bulbs and an
actual conspiracy
that made them worse
[Music]
this video was sponsored by nordvpn more
about them
at the end of the video i am outside
livermore fire station number six and in
here
they have the longest continuously on
light bulb
in the world it has been on for 120
years since 1901 there it is huh
it's not even connected to a light
switch but it does have a backup battery
and generator
so the big question is how has this
light bulb lasted so long
it was manufactured by hand not long
after commercial light bulbs were first
invented
in yet it has been running for over a
million hours
way longer than any light bulb today is
meant to last
a while back a friend of mine told me
this story that
someone had invented a light bulb that
would last forever
years ago but they never sold it because
an everlasting light bulb makes for a
terrible business model
i mean you would never have any repeat
customers and eventually you would run
out of people to sell light bulbs to
i thought this story sounded ridiculous
if you could make an everlasting light
bulb
then everyone would buy your light bulb
over the competitors
and so you could charge really high
prices make a lot of money even if
demand
would eventually dry up i just couldn't
imagine that we had better light bulbs
in the past
and then intentionally made them worse
but it turns out
i was wrong at least sort of
inventing a viable electric light was
hard
i mean this is the typical incandescent
design which just involves passing
electric current through a material
making it so hot that it glows you know
less than five percent of the electrical
energy comes out as light
the other 95 percent is released as heat
so these are really heat bulbs which
give off a little bit of light
as a byproduct you know the temperature
of the filament can get up to
2800 kelvin that is half as hot as the
surface of the sun
at temperatures like those most
materials melt and if they don't melt
they burn which is why in the 1840s
warren de la rue came up with the idea
of putting the filament in a vacuum bulb
so there's no oxygen to react with by
1879
thomas edison had made a bulb with a
cotton thread filament
that lasted 14 hours other inventors
created bulbs with platinum filaments or
other carbonized materials and gradually
the lifespan of bulbs
increased the filaments changed from
carbon to tungsten
which has a very high melting point and
by the early 1920s
average bulb lifetimes were approaching
2 000 hours with
some lasting 2500 hours but this
is when lifetimes stopped getting longer
and started getting shorter
in geneva switzerland just before
christmas 1924
there was a secret meeting of top
executives from the world's
leading light bulb companies phillips
international general electric
tokyo electric osram from germany and
the uk's
associated electric among others they
formed what became known
as the phoebus cartel named after
phoebus the greek god of light
there all these companies agreed to work
together
to help each other by controlling the
world's supply
of light bulbs in the early days of the
electrical industry there had been
lots of different small light bulb
manufacturers but
by now they had largely been
consolidated into these big corporations
each dominant in a particular part of
the world the biggest threat they all
faced was from longer lasting light
bulbs
for example in 1923 osram sold
63 million light bulbs but the following
year they sold only 28 million
light bulbs were lasting too long eating
into sales
so all the companies in the cartel
agreed to reduce the lifespan of their
bulbs
to 1 000 hours cutting the existing
average
almost in half
but how could each company ensure that
the other companies would actually
follow the rules
and make shorter lasting light bulbs
after all it would be in each of their
individual interests to make a better
product to outsell the others well to
enforce the thousand
hour limit each of the manufacturers had
to send in sample bulbs from their
factories
and they were tested on big test stands
like this one
if a bulb lasted significantly longer
than a thousand hours
well then the company was fined if a
bulb lasted longer than three thousand
hours
well the fine was 200 swiss francs for
every
thousand bulbs sold and there are
records of these fines
being issued to companies but how do you
make a worse light bulb in the first
place
well the same engineers who had
previously been tasked with extending
the lifespan
now had to find ways to decrease it so
they tried
different materials different shaped
filaments and thinner connections
and if you look at the data they were
successful
ever since the formation of the cartel
the lifespan of light bulbs steadily
decreased
so that by 1934 the average lifespan was
just
1205 hours and just as they had planned
sales increased for cartel members by 25
in the four years after 1926
and even though the cost of components
came down the cartel kept prices
virtually unchanged so they increased
their profit margins
so did people know that the light bulb
companies were conspiring together to
make their products worse
no the phoebus cartel claimed that its
purpose was to
increase standardization and efficiency
of light bulbs
i mean they did establish this screw
thread as standard you can find it on
virtually all light bulbs
around the world now but all evidence
points to the cartels being motivated by
profits and
increased sales not by what was best for
consumers
so one of the reasons this light bulb
has lasted so long is because
it was made before the cartel era
another reason
is because the filament has always been
run at low power
just four or five watts it was meant to
be a night light for the fire station to
provide
just enough light so that firemen
wouldn't run into things at night
and the fact that it was always on
reduced the thermal cycling of the
filament and components
limiting the stress caused by thermal
expansion and contraction
the fibus cartel was initially planned
to last at least until 1955
but it fell apart in the 1930s it was
already struggling due to
outside competition and non-compliance
amongst some of its members
but the outbreak of world war ii is
really what finished it off so
this cartel was dead but its methods
survived to this day there are lots of
companies out there
that intentionally shorten the lifespan
of their products
it's a tactic known now as planned
obsolescence
this was actually the subject of casey
neistat's first viral video
all the way back in 2003 thank you for
calling apple my name is ryan may i have
your first name please
casey all right what seems to be the
issue today i have an
ipod that i bought about 18 months ago
and the battery is dead on it
18 months okay it's passed it's here
which basically means for um
it'll there'll be a charge of 255
plus a mailing fee to send it to us to
read to refurbish
to correct it but at that price you know
you might as well go get a new one
this video got millions of views in a
time before youtube or social media
and it spawned a class class-action
lawsuit which apple settled out of court
but it didn't stop the company from
practicing planned obsolescence
after an ios update in 2017 users of
older iphones found
apps loading significantly slower or the
device shutting down altogether
apple said they throttled performance to
protect the battery
of older devices and increase their
longevity
of course that wouldn't be an issue if
the battery were replaceable
in a series of lawsuits that concluded
in 2020
apple was fined or reached settlements
to pay hundreds of
millions of dollars undoubtedly this
amount pales in comparison to the extra
revenue they generate by
limiting the lifespan of their products
but some would argue that planned
obsolescence isn't just about greed
but that it's also good for everyone
during the great depression in the 1930s
when as much as a quarter of americans
were out of work
and american real estate broker bernard
london proposed
mandatory planned obsolescence as a way
to get people back to work and lift
america out of the depression
he wrote i would have the government
assign a lease of life
to shoes and homes and machines when
they are first created
and they would be sold and used within
the term of their existence
definitely known by the consumer after
the allotted time had expired these
things would be
legally dead and would be controlled by
the duly appointed governmental agency
and
destroyed if there is widespread
unemployment
now this might sound like a wild fringe
idea
but people were clearly afraid of being
put out of work by technological
progress
and products that were too good there
was even a popular
oscar-nominated film about it this is
the man
in the white suit from 1951 it's about a
scientist who
invents the perfect fiber it won't stain
or break or fray
i think i've succeeded in the
copolymerization of amino acid residues
and carbohydrate molecules
both containing ionic groups it's really
perfectly simple
the academy award nomination was for
best screenplay
i kid you not anyway
everyone is initially excited about our
hero's scientific discovery
he makes a suit out of the thread and it
has to be white because the fiber is so
stain resistant it can't even be dyed
but this is when trouble strikes the
factory owners
realize they won't be able to sell as
much of this thread because it's so
durable
and the workers worry it'll put them out
of a job well i got you
scientists leave things alone
what about my bitter washing when
there's no washing to do
this is when you get the climactic scene
where factory workers and factory owners
team up to chase down the scientist to
destroy him
and his invention and believe it or not
this movie may have been
inspired by real events in the 1940s the
synthetic fiber nylon replaced
silk in stockings and it was so durable
that the products became an overnight
sensation
there were literal riots when women
tried to get their hands on them
when the manufacturers realized they had
made the product
too good they didn't destroy the fiber
but they did follow the example of the
phoebus cartel
they instructed their engineers and
scientists to find ways to weaken the
product
to shorten its lifespan so people would
have to buy more
now it seems like consumers are finally
fighting back against planned
obsolescence
in the european union and in over 25
states in the u.s
there's proposed legislation to enshrine
the right to repair
these laws would force manufacturers to
make it easier to repair
their products they would have to
provide information and access to parts
so you could replace a battery or fix a
cracked screen at a third party repair
shop without voiding your warranty
so if the right to repair does become
law does that mean artificial
obsolescence will be gone for good sadly
no because there is one last thing
manufacturers can use to make their
products
obsolete which is you
henry ford released the first
mass-market car the model t
in 1908 and he envisioned it like a
workhorse
an affordable tool that wouldn't wear
out a bit like
the everlasting light bulb in 1922 ford
said
we want the man who buys one of our cars
never to have to buy another
we never make an improvement that
renders any previous model
obsolete but by 1920
55 of american families already owned a
car
nearly everyone that could afford one
had one
and that same year there was a small
economic downturn driving down sales for
both ford
and general motors in 1921
dupont the chemical and paint company
took over the controlling share in
general motors
and they started experimenting with
painting cars different colors
up until then henry ford had said you
could have whatever color you like
so long as it's black it took a couple
years of testing but in 1924
gm released their first cars in
different colors
and soon after they introduced a trick
that feels
very familiar now each new year they
would introduce
cars in different colors
the goal wasn't just to make ford's
model t look outdated but to make their
own cars feel outdated every year
encouraging customers to trade in their
old cars for shiny new ones
years later gm's head of design harley
earl candidly discussed his role in
creating what he called
dynamic obsolescence our big job is to
hasten
obsolescence in 1934 the average car
ownership span was five years
now which was 1955 it is two years
when it is one year we will have a
perfect score
by the time he said this general motors
was the most valuable company in the
world
and it sold half of all vehicles
purchased in the u.s
every year
[Music]
these days the world's most valuable
company apple
seems to have copied directly out of
this playbook i mean new styles every
year
check new special colors every year
check
marginal technological improvement check
i mean is this
useful innovation or just a gimmick the
inspiration for general motors and hence
for apple comes from
fashion where real innovation is all but
impossible so the only way to make
people feel the urgency to get out there
and buy
is to create styles that last but one
season
the trouble then is you run through
these styles too quickly and then what
are you supposed to do
we'll just recycle the styles from a few
decades ago
the iphone also shows this recycling
trend
i mean just look at the way the edges
were initially rounded
and then they were squared off and then
they were rounded again
and now they're squared off and how much
do you want to bet that the iphone 14
has
rounded edges i think the point is that
with design and styling there is no best
there's only different which is
apparently enough to remind us
that we don't have the latest and
greatest and so we have to rush out and
keep
buying the only type of obsolescence we
should support
is technological which brings us back to
the light bulb
you know in the last 20 years light
bulbs have gone from
incandescent which was basically
unchanged for 100 years
to compact fluorescent and now to led
these use just a tenth of the energy and
can last anywhere from
10 to 50 times longer
yeah that's pretty bright so you're more
likely
to sell your house than to have to
replace an led bulb that you've
installed inside it so we've finally
reached the point
of what is essentially an everlasting
light bulb
[Music]
hey this video was sponsored by nordvpn
you know i am featured in an episode of
the british tv program
qi it's a show i really like and i'd
highly recommend it if you haven't seen
it already and it's on netflix
but only if you're in the uk i feel like
tv and film are still trapped
in antiquated business models where they
divide up the world into broadcast
territories
that doesn't make a lot of sense now
that information can flow freely through
the internet
luckily using nordvpn anyone can set
their location
to the uk and watch whatever they like
if you're interested in seeing what
streamers have to offer in different
countries
you can get a huge discount on a
two-year plan at nordvpn.com
veritasium use code veritasium to get an
extra month
free and using nordvpn you can also
protect your privacy by masking your ip
address
in fact you can change your ip twice to
cover your web traffic
with an extra layer of security nordvpn
has a no logs policy they don't track
collect or share your private data which
is what a lot of the world's biggest
companies are trying to do right now
so for privacy when browsing and access
to all the shows the world has to offer
go to nordvpn.com veritasium for a huge
discount
of a two-year plan and use code
veritasium to get one additional month
free
and this is all risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee
so i want to thank nordvpn for
sponsoring veritasium
and i want to thank you for watching